We said that we will explain why we need a better predictor in two ways.
This was one way, the CPI gets a lot better. The other way will be to see
how much waste there is from a mis-prediction. So in a five stage pipeline,
what's happening really we have three stages that are relevent.
The one where we re, resolve the branches. And then we have to destroy two
instructions that we have fetched if this branch has been mis-predicted. So
a mis-prediction costs us two instructions here. In a deeper pipeline,
what happens is, we have our branch, and for ten cycles, we have been fetching
things. Some a mis-prediction now costs us ten instructions worth of work,
and that means that avoiding mis-predictions becomes more important. And
finally, when we have a four instruction per cycle processor that
resolves branches in the 11th stage. After we gave fetched this branch,
we have fetched a lot of instructions. After we fetch the branch, we fetched
four instructions in the next cycle, and four instructions in the next cycle. So
now when we miss predict a branch we waste 40 instructions that we
could have done if the prediction was correct. So the cost of a mis-prediction
is higher in terms of instructions that we have just wasted. And
that means that again it's much more important to predict branches correctly.